[Musique]
date de naissance
vendredi 31 décembre 1937. tu
vis avec ta fille en ce moment
oui
dans mon appartement tu vois la situation est très
simple
j'habite dans cet appartement depuis 30 ans
c'est moi et ma fille est
très  ça m'intéresse pas de papa de quoi
tu parles
alors elle a emménagé avec cet homme qu'elle a rencontré
je suis là pour t'aider
je ne sais pas ce qu'elle
me prépare mais elle prépare quelque
chose que je sais
quelqu'un a vu mon  regarde ça a été
volé non c'est arrivé nous savons que ça n'a pas
été
c'est moi euh c'est quoi ce non-sens
où est anne de quoi tu parles
où est-il
je suis là hein
je n'ai pas besoin d'aide nous devons
trouver un  arrangement différent
arrête de parler comme ça je ne quitte pas
mon appartement
je ne quitte pas mon appartement
papa as-tu eu tes pilules
puis-je te poser une question combien de temps
as-tu l'intention de traîner prendre
ruiner la vie de ta fille
[Musique]
qui sont  toi exactement
[Musique] et
moi papa
qui suis-je exactement
toi